[Music]
we all started I mean you know just
specifically Hannibal Arturo and us none
of us had any experience we didn't have
like TV experience we're working on
broad city all year but Hannibal and
Arturo are going and acting on different
things and I really felt their
experience come back to the set and feed
the set it's good to see everybody it's
good to see just how they've grown as
actors as as businesswomen as creators
they've both directed episodes now it's
been great to see the progression maybe
some penis be weak they're so talented
both of them in their own individual
ways and I hope that we keep writing to
their strengths but their strengths keep
expanding and I feel like I learned more
about how good they were from directing
them okay so we have to talk about this
whole relationship thing what think
about what we have sacrificed to enter
the sexless barn party people get
emotionally invested with characters
I've done it before with the television
show would somebody break up like they
broke up I can't believe it I want them
to get back together
oh my dear hello my fluid dude they
never really doubted that I'll be back
in there and I didn't but I think the
fans just really thought I was off the
show he's my boyfriend
having sex with a girl afterwards she's
like so you know if you're gonna be back
hey this isn't the time for that first
of all this isn't that what we're here
for this is not a meet and greet this is
not an interview I don't want to talk
storylines with you right now I just met
you four hours ago
[Music]